[Musik]
und jan o meine lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen hier heute und so
zweiten episode minecraft mit luca
stachel 24 befinden uns noch immer in
unserem kleinen süßen wald hier in dem
wir ja dort hinten gespannt sind und
dort auch der sumpf bar uns das krokodil
getötet hat in der ersten episode fest
dahin ist er seit haben ich hasse den
[ __ ] na ja meine lieben freunde falls
ihr die erste episode einfach nur luca
noch nicht gesehen haben sollte dann
müsst ihr euch die direkt jetzt noch mal
anschauen denn hier einzusteigen macht
gar keinen sinn allerdings habe ich in
der letzten episode also in der ersten
episode mit luca bereits gesagt heute
erfahrt ihr und seht auch zum ersten mal
was das intro von minecraft mitnutzer
staffel 2 sein wird und das habt ihr ja
gerade gesehen und das sieht doch schon
im titel eingeblendet ich weiß dass der
ein oder andere in die kommentare
schreiben jetzt mensch das ist total
simpel das intro ja das wollte ich aber
auch weil ich ja noch nicht genau weiß
wo dieses pack hingehen wird und das
intro von michael von luca staffel als
das kam ja irgendwie erst ab folge 20 30
oder so dazu und da gab es ja schon
insider wusste schon okay ich bin auf
einer insel und weiter und so fort das
intro existiert allerdings seitdem ich
das komplette projekt hier noch nicht
mal gestartet habe denn ich habe jerome
gesagt dann findet ihr auch und in der
beschreibung verlinkt ja er hat mir das
intro gemacht ich hab ihm einfach nur
gesagt nur dich brauchen ganz ganz
simples intro irgendwie alle bio mit
drin ich weiß noch nicht wo ich geboren
werde ich weiß nicht worauf das ganze
hier hinauslaufen wird ich weiß nicht wo
die reise hingeht mache alle millionen
mit rein und einfach irgendwie dass ich
dadurch laufen die stadt mit nix und am
ende bin ich am ende und schaffst dann
irgendwie dann steht ein kraft mit luca
das war so mein gedanke weil ich ein
ganz kurzes knapp ist intro wollte weil
es geht ja nicht ums intro habe kein
bock auf den halben minuten langes intro
wir haben gar keine zeit mehr zu groß zu
reden die sonne geht schon fast wieder
runter sondern ich möchte einfach auf
simlisch klimas und jetzt was ist was
guckst du so geh mal zum friseur du pic
san francisco
[Applaus]
hatte er gerade zusammen mit gut meine
lieben freunde ich mache mir erst mal
noch ein paar stocker eben weil ich mir
eine neue achse machen wollte dass wir
noch ein bisschen bäume abfällen können
und ich wollte mir noch ein paar mehr
fackeln machen ich habe nämlich jetzt 48
stück das sollte erstmal reichen ich
brauche jetzt auch erstmal ein bettchen
hier ab und meine kräftigen mensch denn
ich brauche auf jeden fall wasser um
meine samen anzupflanzen damit ich doch
eine kleine farm machen kann hier ist
was aber keines theoretisch sogar direkt
neben machen da nehme ich mir mal eben
fix ich meine wer krank wir sehen ja
auch unten wir haben einen knochen
daraus können wir uns knochen mir machen
und ich benötige eine hacke so damit
nicht den boden hier bearbeiten kann
also zack zack zack und hier und hier
können wir aber leben machen dann nehme
ich jetzt mal eben schnell meine
weizenkörner kann die schweiz als land
bekommen wir direkt den fortschritt
hobbygärtner und ich nehme meinen
knochen gehen und kann mir hier direkt
ein bisschen weizen holen und hier
klappt es nicht benötige insgesamt drei
weiß damit ich mir ein boot machen kann
allerdings dass ich das hier erst mal so
ein bisschen wachsen hier kann ich noch
im neuen ran pflanzen und wir haben
darum ein schwein
schön ich muss mich auf jeden fall ein
bisschen sputen ich nehme den kräftigen
table ich erst mal wieder mit und bewege
mich wieder in richtung hörde da vorne
da waren ja erst la vie so oder so in
der letzten episode minecraft wir sind
einfach erstmal folge 2
es ist so geisteskrank wir haben alles
noch vor uns
ich hab so bot alles zu entdecken wir
waren noch nicht in die richtung wir
waren noch nicht in der richtung im wald
wir waren noch nicht bei dem sumpf bei
dem krokodil dahin und wir waren auch
noch nicht dort
ich hab so bock auf dieses projekt ich
hoffe ja auch ich hoffe ihr bleibt dran
ich hoffe ihr seid aber nennt von meinem
kanal wissen das
diese leuchtet diese blume so ich bin
eine große menge wieder auf eure hilfe
angewiesen also nutzt die kommentar
sektion bitte voll und ganz aus haut in
die tasten und gibt tipps für einerseits
minecraft 1.17 aber auch für diese alex
mops mod die installiert habe und auch
für bei uns oppland ja so diese ganzen
neuen biome die ich hier habe ich nehme
ganz kurze fackel in die linke hand so
dass wir so ein bisschen beleuchtung mit
drin haben und dann schauen wir mal ob
wir hier eventuell
noch eisen kriegen um uns dann damit
vielleicht einen
ihren weg um uns eventuell einen eimer
zu machen so dass wir uns eine eigene
farm irgendwo bauen können wo wir das
wollen mit dem wasser meine lieben
freunde
das geht dann ganz klar schon mal in die
richtung des ersten kommentar den ich
heute ein werden möchte uns war dieser
hier
lernst du dich vegan ja mache ich
ernähre mich in diesem projekt auch
wieder vegan ich habe keine lust
irgendwelche tiere zu töten die einzigen
monster die ich angreifen werde bzw die
einzigen mops nicht angreifen werde
werden ob sein die auch mich angreifen
also
[Musik]
ist das
der stein sieht
irgendwie anders aus als die anderen
steine
ok schuldig ist ein ganz normaler
bruchstein gewesen ich möchte mich auf
jeden fall wieder komplett vegetarisch
in diesem projekt ernähren also ich
möchte keine tiere töten und dann
irgendwie das fleisch von denen es noch
keine fische essen und
sofort dass hier jetzt noch sind das
auch in welche ärzte oben rechts steht
neue rezepte verfügbar was ist das
kupfer mäßig oder was ist rohkupfer das
muss ich wahrscheinlich dann ihn wie
braten im ofen oder so schreibt mir gern
alles und in die kommentare was ich
irgendwie machen sollte ich weiß auch
nicht ob jetzt noch irgendwelche monster
auf uns warten bisher ist hier kein
monster also mal schauen die hürde ist
hier auch schon wieder vorbei ich nehme
mir noch mal eben kurz die kohle weg ihr
seht auch schon oben rechts und damit
gehe ich jetzt direkt aufs nächste thema
fürs heutige video einen die minimap da
habe ich euch ja in der letzten episode
also in folge eins gefragt ob ich die
minimap einblenden soll oder nicht und
es war eine fifty fifty entscheidung die
hälfte hatten einst geschrieben also pro
mini map und die andere hälfte zwei
geschrieben von wegen kein bock auf eine
minimap es gab vor und nachteile und pro
und contra es gab leute die gesagt haben
wenn schlug eine minimap macht sinn weil
oft wenn not am liebsten wenn das weiß
man nicht so genau wo du dich gerade
befindet und dann kann man so auf jeden
fall sehen wo du gerade bist wo du hin
läuft und dann weiß direkt was sache ist
viele leute meinen allerdings auch ein
stück hat das macht gar keinen sinn mit
einer mini map weil wir dann sachen
entdecken bevor du sie entdeckst quasi
also dass beispielsweise ich eine
festung sehr bevor ich überhaupt bei der
festung bin weil sie zuerst auf der
minimap angezeigt wird ich muss direkt
moment petrausch wohnung schlafen gehen
ich habe gar kein bock dass irgendwelche
monster com
habe es aber geschafft
dann ist der fuchs
ich idiot alter da wurden auch in die
kommentare geschrieben fuchs gibt schon
vor langem ein ordner ist wieder diese
gefühle gewesen rechts sagt na ja meine
lieben freunde werden die nacht auf
jeden fall überlebt die sonne geht auf
sieht so schön aus
[Musik]
das ist dass
ich weiß es nicht
minecraft ist so schön vor allem mit
diesem waldweg gerade aber gut ich darf
ich nicht von der schöner hier wieder
ablenken lassen wir schauen mal nach
unserem weizen jahr und ob das
vielleicht ein bisschen gewachsen ist
sonst laufen wir so ein bisschen weiter
weil ich mir auch generell gedacht habe
ich will jetzt nicht passte
[Musik]
ich finde das spiel so voll aber gut ich
habe mir auf jeden fall gedacht ich
möchte so lange ich jetzt noch keine
kiste benötige weil ich habe mal
inventar jedoch überhaupt nicht voll so
lange ich noch keine kiste benötige
macht gar keinen sinn dass ich mir
irgendwie hier schon eine base aufbau
weil das ist cool hier die kleine
lichtung und so hab ich will endlich
auch ein bisschen rumlaufen ich will so
ein paar sachen entdecken und ich würde
sagen gelaufen einfach mal in die
richtung dahin wir sind ja da gespannt
sind hier lange laufen doch was treibt
weiter in diese richtung und ja mit der
minimap habe ich mir auf jeden fall
gedacht dann 50 5 die paar leute wollen
ein paar leute wollen sie nicht wir
nehmen sie einfach mal und der
kompromiss auf den ich dann ein bisschen
eingegangen bin dass ich nicht überlegt
habe ist dieser hier wir machen einen
dreier zoom normalerweise hat die
minimap oben rechts einen einsatz summen
wenn ihr das vergleich beispielsweise
lernt euch hier mal ein screenshot ein
mit der minimap aus folge nummer eins da
hat man viel mehr gesehen deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht ich suche einfach mehr
ran man sieht bei der minimap fast gar
nichts also man sieht so ein bisschen
mein umkreis von 30 blocken oder so
vielleicht wenn überhaupt da wird nicht
viel gespeicherte und gerade wenn man
den höhlen geht oder wenn ich mich
irgendwie verlauf oder so ist macht es
schon sinn was die gasträume ich finde
ich einfach mal so ein bisschen bäume
wieder ab so ein bisschen holz bekommen
und die axt auch dementsprechend ein
bisschen nutzen können auf jeden fall
haben wir deswegen die minimap auf jeden
fall mit am start ich hoffe das ist für
euch alle in ordnung falls sie da noch
mehr tipps für die mini map pack oder
ähnliches schreibt auch gerne in die
kommentare und was ja auch viel in die
kommentare geschrieben wurde waren
geräusche für die monster und da bin ich
ganz ehrlich komme ich erst zu wenn ich
die monster sehe da möchte ich jetzt
nicht spoilern macht am meisten sinn
wenn wir uns sehen dass ich dann einfach
zeigen was ich mir dabei gedacht habe
deswegen konzentrieren uns heute erstmal
darauf so ein bisschen hier alles zu
erkunden ich habe da wirklich bock drauf
so ein bisschen herumzulaufen bist du
vielleicht nächste nacht anbricht und
wir dann heute noch die ersten monster
sehen hier fordere ich den blog einfach
mal ab dann können wir jetzt ein
bisschen weiter hoch laufen ich weiß
auch gar nicht wo es mich hin verschlägt
ich habe einfach bock herumzulaufen ich
habe keinen konto als ich habe fast
keine sache nicht was kein leben mehr
ich muss eigentlich auch mal was essen
ist egal einfach rum laufen einfach so
ein bisschen entdecken ich habe richtig
bock auf dieses projekt ich nehme ich
auch mal direkt ein bisschen zucker mit
damit wir daraus uns eventuell dann
demnächst sogar schon bücher bauen
können und alles ein bisschen schneller
vonstatten geht mir unter die kommentare
geschrieben luca macht's mal in dieser
staffel so dass du schneller ins ende
kommst so dass du danach nochmal ins
ende gehen kannst damit du dir mit
der fliege die ganze zeit im kreis
jetzt nicht mehr
sind das möwen
hob er von einer angestellten einer
nordsee
doch
bevor ich angeklagt werde oder sind aber
auch cool aus hier
er könnte also eine unterwasser base
bauen ist auch so ein kleiner hafen hier
gefühlt wir laufen wir weiter in die
richtung ich habe einfach bock ein
bisschen zu laufen hier ist es einfach
aufgefallen und das hat mir ein bisschen
in minecraft staffel 1 auch gefehlt dass
wir einfach auf dieser insel waren und
so ein bisschen daran gezwungen waren zu
bleiben ich konnte da nicht halbe meile
durch den ozean schwimmen deswegen habe
ich hier bock auf jeden fall so ein
bisschen zu entdecken und einfach mich
da niederzulassen wo ich bock aber es
kann sein dass wir die ersten folgende
unterwegs sein werden
[Musik]
und stinkt ihr baby
waschbeckens massenmails native to
trains an ich kann kein englisch
die sind auf jeden fall friedlich
deswegen marquis iii
möchte zu weizen
frist eine scheiß körner selbst du
kakadu
tschuldigung mister kulinarium den weg
du fettsack
ja schon hier vorne haben wir noch ein
bisschen zuckerrohr das nämlich auch
direkt mal mit das wird wirklich später
extrem wichtig damit wir uns diese
bücherregale machen können und so ein
bisschen verzaubern können gefordert
auch süßes ist ein kleiner see mit so
ein bisschen sand und wir haben halt
diesen wald hier ich feiere das wirklich
extrem mit diesem neuen billionen
was haben wir hier davon irgendwas um
geflogen ich weiß dass wieder ebenso
komische fliege war oder irgendwie sowas
die rege mich auch total auf bitte also
wirklich die sache nämlich am meisten
aufregen so einfach fliegen und haben
hier kurz davor eine perfekte gar direkt
bei habe
und eine fliege
und noch ein raab
naja was ist das hier
[Musik]
sind irgendwie blumen aber auch voll
viele blätter auf dem boden
aber irgendwie voll schön
voll viele blumen sogar
hier ist wasser hier können wir
theoretisch müssen was anbauen
was geht denn hier ab guck mal wie viele
blumen hier sind das ist ja unfassbar
schön hier und wir haben wasser hier
vorne
und schnee
ich glaube ich bleibe hier
ich glaube ich bleib direkt ihr name ist
kommt nimmt
und dann fertig er hat es wirklich im
maul er hat es wirklich im märz geht das
team hoffentlich sehe ich hier nach
nicht aus wie sandra das war gemein ja
meine lieben freunde ich würde sagen
dass ich mich hier einfach mal
niederlasse ich werde mir in der
nächsten episode denke ich mal hier so
eine kleine base aufbauen das ist ja
unfassbar schöne den ganzen blumen hier
ich hab's an dem normalen blumen biomüll
minecraft mal so ein bisschen geärgert
dass es mir ihnen die zu viele blumen
waren aber hier ist es eine ganz schöne
ein ganz schöner kompromiss aus blumen
und wir haben auch noch ein bisschen
hier von diesen blättern überall
rumstehen und ein paar bäumchen wir
haben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was ist das
hat sich da schon immer hin gebaut
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich habe keinen
nerv gerade dafür ich dort hinten hin zu
bewegen ich will in dieser folge hat
sich auch noch sterben vor allem mit so
wenig es ziemlich unten habe ich werde
mir auf jeden fall jetzt hier unten mal
eben kurz habe ich ein bisschen ehrlich
nur eine erde perfekt ich weiß nicht wo
wir noch ein bisschen wasser haben wir
haben hier wasser perfekt hier vorne
kann ich direkt in baum ich werde jetzt
einfach mal so ein bisschen was an
pflanzen ein bisschen weizen so dass wir
dann hoffentlich in der nächsten episode
hier schon so ein bisschen essen am
start haben um und
[Musik]
was sind das für teile
ich habe ein bisschen schiss
ich habe bock auf das alles ist das bei
ihnen
[Musik]
ach guck mal hier sind auch noch
stinktiere
[Musik]
das sind wieder andere sagen ist aber
auch egal meine lieben freunde die sonne
geht da hinten schon wieder runter akt
von daher würde ich sagen bewege ich
mich in richtung bettchen aber doch
gleich mal schlafen gehen das ist
wunderschön hier die ecke ich finde das
richtig geil mit diesen blumen mit dem
schnee auch so ein bisschen geht jetzt
mittlerweile hier november in richtung
winter schon rüber und mit diesen ganzen
blättern ja auch überall zudem haben wir
auch noch wasser also ich feiere ist
wirklich extrem kraft wir haben so ein
bisschen möglichkeiten hier einiges zu
bauen von daher wenn euch die heutige
episode minecraft mit luca staffel 2
gefallen hat dann lasse gerne einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier und
jetzt meinen kanal und kriegt
selbstverständlich auf die glocke wenn
ihr neue videos von nicht verpassen
wollte seine benachrichtigung bekommen
wollt sobald ich ein neues video
hochladen die nächste episode minecraft
mit luca folge 3 geht übermorgen um 18
uhr online morgen kommt ein anderes
video what's up fällt dann möchte ich
mich mal wieder dran setzen und da ein
bisschen was zu machen also wenn ihr
tipps habt schreibt gerne die kommentare
wenn ich welche vorschläge habe
irgendwelche ideen was ich machen soll
schreibst ja auch gerne in die
kommentare
heute haben wir unsere welt so ein
bisschen entdeckt ich hab ich das neue
intro gezeigt wir haben jetzt erstmal
ein bisschen niedergelassen ich glaube
der nächsten episode werde hier unsere
erste kleine base hin bauen sondern
bisschen habe ich auf jeden fall bock
drauf und dann werden wir hier mal alles
so ein bisschen erkunden vielleicht
meine höhle geht und so ein bisschen
schon mal vorbereiten und ich gehe jetzt
auf jeden fall schlafen meine lieben
freunde aber ich liebe ich habe richtig
bock auf dieses projekt nicht bis morgen
übermorgen
[Musik]